[Music]
one of your first jobs because I
remember this lived in New York for a
long time you were a character called
little bit of luck
it helped advertise the lottery and
these the posters were everywhere the
billboards were everywhere the
commercials were everywhere let's just
take a quick quick look I'm feeling
really good about winning take back
today you should all you need is me a
little bit of luck if she has a little
bit of lack what about me no no that's
my little bit of luck right baby baby
there's enough of me to go around for
everyone
oh really well how's that holy odds the
winning take 5 or 1 and 9 there's a
hundred thousand winners every day I'm
gonna take you home was that your first
big job it was my first big job it was
you know I'm very grateful to it I you
know how I choose to think of it it's
like it got me off of my friend's couch
you know and you know provided me with a
little bit of money in my wallet a
little bit of food in my belly and a
little bit of spring in my step
yeah you know yeah yeah some some might
say that it was a Jewish minstrel
character a Jewish demon tricking poor
people in
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that was well maybe you've betrayed your
PI thought I don't think that no no no
no oh no Jews came up with it I was like
these middle-aged ad execs they'd be
like Bret let me talk to you for a
second you know what this character
means to people do you know that a
seven-year-old and Hackensack dressed up
as you for Halloween no I didn't and I
wish I still didn't know that doesn't
really give me a lot of faith and but
did that did you it was that pretty much
the end of your starving period or after
the you know that I think I starved a
little bit after that you know but not
not so much it did give me a little a
little oomph you know right I in my life
those ads were around it for a while
they were they were yeah I mean we went
a couple runs and actually I I met well
I didn't meet my fiancee there a fiancee
what a terrible word I didn't meet my
wife to be so dumb fiancee fiancee it's
trying to sound fancy about something
that hasn't happened yet
you know such a strange complaint I've
never heard anybody complain about that
oh I know people complain about a lot of
people hate the word fiancee candid your
intended intent intended that he rolled
me true he drove that's see that's
romantic
yeah fiancee it's like I don't know it's
yeah it's like you know wearing a trash
bag and ordering a latte you know fake
does that make sense I think you may not
you may not have a fiancee anymore
where you have to worry about it she
hates it worse than me she punches me in
the mouth every time I say it so what
hang it huh I like getting punched in
the mouth
all right you're a weird guy
you